bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est le dernier rendez vous de la
semaine mais on a encore plein de choses
à vous dire vous allez voir sur quatre
sujets que nous avons sélectionnés et
qu'on découvre tout de suite en images
dimanche dernier emmanuel macron a
commencé son itinérance mémorielle qui
lui vaut des altercations parfois vives
avec des français c'est un chemin de
croix disent les médias pas du tout
c'est un vrai bonheur du président de la
république qui dit vrai vous lui
donnerez votre point de vue et puis on
reviendra sur ces chiffres inquiétants
de la hausse de l'antisémitisme en
france pour se poser cette question qui
anime le débat public
sommes nous en train de revivre une
atmosphère qui était celle de l'europe
dans les années 30 on parlera aussi
d'une note de la fondation jean jaurès
est un think tank de centre gauche qui
dit que finalement françois hollande
n'était peut-être pas si mal alors
faut-il réhabiliter d'anciens présidents
de la république nous vous donnerai
votre point de vue et puis nous
parlerons du foot business
savez vous que la star neymar du paris
saint-germain touche 375000 euros par
mois mais pas pour jouer au foot
simplement pour aller saluer les
supporteurs à la fin des matchs est ce
que tout ça vous dégoûte ou est-ce que
après tout ça n'est que la règle du jeu
eh bien on se posera la question avec
nous on se posera même toutes ces
questions avec nos quatre invités
bonsoir julia de funès ravis de vous
accueillir dans cette émission vous êtes
philosophe elle est aussi expert des
ressources humaines et du management et
vous avez co écrit avec l'excellent
nicolas bouzou
la tragédie humaine qui est un livre sur
les errements
oui la comédie humaine accepte tout ça
n'est pas si grave
c'est sur les errements du management
moderne c'est un énorme succès on en est
à plus de 40000 exemplaires vendus je
crois et c'est mérité bonsoir guillaume
bernard pas vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'iss s je sais pas si
vous avez déjà vendu 48 l'exemplaire de
la guerre à droite aura bien lieu
le mouvement dextrogyre mais sinon vous
allez sûrement y arriver exact la sosta
mérite et c'est publié aux éditions
desclée de brouwer bonsoir daniel
bilalian vous êtes l'ancien directeur
des sports de france télévisions entre
autres titres de gloire et de fort de
compétences et vient d'être réédité un
de vos livres le camp de la goutte d'eau
rawa ruska 1942 1944
c'est aux presses de la cité et puis
notre confrère étienne girard est là
aussi bon soir etienne journaliste
politique à marianne on voit tout de
suite la couverture de marianne lactalis
un scandale français
après le lait contaminé l'évasion
fiscale
nous n'allons pas parler d'évasion
fiscale aujourd'hui encore qu'avec les
footballeurs et ce serait peut être une
vie intéressant donc on verra ça à la
fin de l'émission
mais on commence par cette itinérance
mémorielle un drôle de nom pour un
déplacement dans l'est de la france afin
pour commémorer le premier conflit
mondial et puis pour aller à la
rencontre des français qui ne ménage pas
impressionnant république c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire
ils se plaignent de l'augmentation de la
csg de la hausse des prix des carburants
et tout ça est donc un peu compliqué
pour le chef de l'état
écouter le bilan que fait de ce voyage
un bilan méchamment négatif
françois ruffin député de la france
insoumise l'un le président il fait son
chemin des dames pourquoi parce que
simplement jupiter vos descend sur terre
jusqu'à maintenant il était à l'elysée
tout était tranquille il croyait qu'il
allait visiter des musées
il croyait qu'il allait visiter des
cimetières il se retrouve face à des
gens bien vivant bien criant et qui lui
exprime la colère qu'ils éprouvent
depuis maintenant un an et un an et demi
alors pour certains ce voyage était
peut-être une erreur parce qu'il expose
trop le président de la république mais
pas du tout répond celui là celui ci
plutôt il est tout à fait enchantés de
ce déplacement il a dit hier c'était
lors de
sa visite à l'usiné renault de maubeuge
c'est un vrai bonheur à vous me voyez je
suis très heureux je suis très heureux
parce que je suis venu parce que c'est
ça le pays
notre pays mais depuis des décennies les
dans cette situation moi je veut l'en
sortir j'ai été élu face au front
national il ya 15 mois j'ai été élu dans
une crise profonde
je ne vais pas rester comme comme on a
toujours fait ne me réfugier derrière
les discours convenus
j'ai jamais pensé que c'était facile ça
et moi j'ai été élu en faisant secouer
et je continuerai à aller mieux mais et
ça continuera jusqu'au bout c'est gérard
c'est de la com où il est sincère le
président de la république fasse appelle
la méthode coué de toute façon il peut
il peut pas dire le contraire
emmanuel macron mais il ya des signes
il ya des signes non verbaux la façon
dont il sourit jaune quand des gens lui
parle la façon dont il les touche de
façon un peu trop prononcée alors que
rien ne rien ne l'y incite en réalité à
qui montre une certaine fébrilité et
qu'il est un peu déstabilisé par ce
qu'il entend depuis le début de la
semaine qu'est ce qu'il avait prévu
emmanuel macron il avait prévu de faire
pendant une semaine
ce qu'il a fait entre les deux tours à
amiens à whirlpool c'est à dire tomber
sur des gens qui râlent et les
convaincre et pied à pied que non son
programme est très bien et qu'il a sauvé
la france etc
sauf qu'à l'époque il avait l'avenir
devant lui là il commence à avoir des
bus de bilan et ce qui se passe c'est
que les gens ils râlent pas ils sont
pour beaucoup
fou de rage et il se retrouve un peu un
peu sans voix face à cette colère
populaire
un convoi dans le nord et dans l'est
depuis le début de la semaine mais je
venais c'est quand même une bonne
méthode de management avant quand il ya
une crise de bad aller au contact et de
ne pas s'enfermer dans son bureau en
ignorant la situation oui en management
en entreprise weeds là en l'occurrence
invoqué le bonheur c'est drôle parce
qu'on est dans une dans l'ère du bonheur
isme absolue il faut toujours dire qu'on
est heureux même quand c'est le drame
mais ça c'est propre à notre société
très bonne risque mais en tout cas ce
qui est frappant a traversé cette
errance mémorable plus que cette unité
itinérance me mémorial c'est que c'est
vraiment
la chute des transcendances et la
victoire de dima nan c'est à dire le
président essaye d'invoquer des sabbats
philosophe qui part oui mais on est à
verdun dans ce lieu historique et les
gens nous parlent évidemment du
carburant du pouvoir d'achat de la
limitation de vitesse etc
et c'est une erreur stratégique je pense
de vouloir justement fixé le discours
trop haut et les gens sont beaucoup plus
soucieux de leur avenir personnel que de
la mémoire ou du souvenir collectif il
suffit pas d'invoquer les grandes causes
et une histoire commune et d'aller en
province pour parer au peuple c'est
vraiment l'illustration de sage trop tôt
mme bernard c'était pourtant ça
ressemblait à une bonne idée d'aller au
contact d'une france un peu délaissé qui
connaît des situations sociales fortes
en temps pour rendre hommage au courage
des français et puis qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
oui mais le problème c'est que c'est le
discours est illisible
ces axes et le mélange des genres si si
l'objectif c'était effectivement de
profiter de cette semaine qui précède le
11 novembre
cent ans après la victoire de 1918 pour
et bien raconté le roman national même
si c'est peut-être un peu has been
maintenant de le faire mais enfin si
c'est pour rendre hommage aux morts
c'est très bien mais en même temps son
propre discours est incohérent parce que
il veut faire cette itinérance
mémorielle mais en même temps il nous
dit que le 11 novembre parce qu'il y
aura la présence de la chancelière
allemande et bien on ne parlera pas des
soldats donc il ya une il ya un mélange
des genres il va faire campagne ou en
tout cas essayer de défendre son début
de bilan et en même temps il veut faire
de la de la mémoire et donc par
conséquent il ya un télescopage entre
les deux et le résultat c'est que ni les
français qu'il rencontre de son
satisfait ni l'objectif qui était et qui
était un bon objectif qui était de
rendre hommage aux morts de se souvenir
d un million trois cent mille français
qui se sont sacrifiés pour la défense de
la patrie
et bien cela on les oublie complètement
et en fait on au lieu de discuter de nos
soldats est et de l'est
la france est bien on je dirais on parle
de la pipolisation et de la présence du
président de la république parmi des
foules hostiles
je trouve ça extrêmement dommage ouais
mais c'est sacrément injuste quand même
daniel bilalian parce que elles existent
ces cérémonies d'hommage ces
commémorations
elles sont très belles d'ailleurs et
trading et puis nous les médias ou les
réseaux sociaux ne parle que des petites
phrases et des et des prises de bec avec
des français mécontents pour les petites
phrases y apprend l'hébreu non c'est
déjà ça permettrait d éviter source très
simple non mais je crois que je
regardais hier sur la télévision du
figaro tout l'après midi il a serré des
mains avec des mots comme je suis
content que vous soyez là c'est bien que
vous soyez là experts on sent qu'il
essaye d'être proche des gens mais on
sent aussi que ce président est
quelqu'un qui n'a jamais été élu au sens
de personnel politique qui n'a jamais
été députée maire etc dont il connaît
pas il connaît pas les gens il connaît
pas les gens c'est pour ça qu'ils c'est
pas leur parler
il ne connaît pas il ne connaît pas la
base on s'est beaucoup moqué des hommes
politiques pendant la campagne dernière
campagne étoiles mais ces gens là ils
vont le marché sur le marché le dimanche
et il discute avec les gens et pourquoi
l'épicerie affirmé la gendarmerie elle
médecins et avec leurs bombes atomiques
qui nous ont détraqué le temps et c'est
donc ils sont habitués ils connaissent
lui il les connaît pas les français
je voyais hier sur sa manière de parler
c'était il essayait d'être sympathique
il essayait d'être proche des gens et on
sent que ils n'y arrivent pas puis
deuxièmement la deuxième chose c'est que
c'est une une semaine
deux itinéraires mais la mémoire des
soldats c'est peut-être un tout petit
peu beaucoup comme chaque fois il en
fait un peu trop et ensuite on mélange
tout c'était vraiment une semaine on
rend hommage aux morts de 14 18 on va
taxer l'essence
le même jour on va également je sais pas
donner des chèques pour tes cents soit
moins cher qui aujourd'hui c'est elle la
réduction du prix du permis de conduire
bon vous faites vous faites hommage aux
soldats de la guerre de 14 pointe à la
ligne point à la ligne
et puis vous allez à des cérémonies et
vous dit vous ne dites rien on vous dit
quelques mots en hommage à nos soldats
etc
qu'est ce que c'est que cette semaine
encore de 2 foutraque là on est dans
tous les sens et ccc monsieur macron qui
mélange tout c'est monsieur macron qui
mange tout alors en commençant
d'ailleurs par cette chose énorme
c'est ce que les soldats de 14-18 sont
des civils qui ont habillé en militaire
quand on savait en 14-18 sap a été vrai
par la suite dans les années 15 ou 16
114 8 comment les gens se sont rués pour
être enrôlé pour défendre leur pays
c'est peut-être obsolète aujourd'hui
mais c'est la vérité on ne dit pas ça on
ne dit pas ça c'est insulter leur
mémoire et ça ne sert à rien il ya un
lien qui s'est rompu avec les français
où c'est seulement un passage à vide
comme en ont connu tous les présidents
de la république au bout d'une année de
mandat parce que les résultats n'avaient
jamais assez vite la différence
peut-être avec les précédents présidents
de la république c'est que mâcon il n'a
pas de lien du construit sur la durée
avec les français il est arrivé un peu
par effraction en 2014 et il a été élu
avec un des circonstances favorables en
2017 il a séduit les français
mais les français ne le connaissais pas
très bien donc le lien il est pas rompu
parce qu'il n'a jamais été extrêmement
profond mais là il ya une vraie
incertitude et une vraie inquiétude
j'ai l'impression à voir les courses que
dit les françaises sur le terrain par
rapport à ce que va faire
emmanuel macron de ce mandat là il s'est
présenté comme le président du pouvoir
d'achat qu'ils allaient tout relancer
force est constater là depuis un an
presque un an et demi tout n'a pas été
relancé et d'ailleurs à peu près toutes
les prises de parole des gens sont sur
ce thème là les prises sur les migrants
il ya très peu de choses sur la sécurité
finalement on entend assez peu de choses
la priorité des gens qui viennent voir
emmanuel macron c'est ça c'est leur
condition de vie et c'est sur ce thème
là que le lien il est en train de
basculer
je viens des finances il ya quand même
un peu d'injustice non pas ce qu'on lui
reprochait au président de la république
que d'être coupé des gens d'être le
président des villes
et puis là-bas il descend vers la france
qu'on appelle désormais périphériques et
puis on le lui reproche à nouveau en
disant que c'est parce qu'il faut
faisait exactement c'est quand même très
facile et je trouve de donner des leçons
morales sur la communication du
président moi je n'aime pas trop ce
positionnement là surtout qu'on me dit
tout et son contraire mais je pense que
plus que la personnalité au la
communication de ce président c'est le
mauvais timing c'est à dire qu'à un
moment les gens attendent qu'on leur
parle de leur quotidien
et là il vient parler de l'histoire et
quand on a besoin d'un peu de grandeur
et de commémoration il est dans le
pragmatisme à tout prix donc entre
l'historique et le pragmatisme
il ya une sorte d hésitation et je pense
que c'est plutôt une histoire de timing
que de personnalités caen lors de la
campagne présidentielle on a vu qu'il
était très magnétique très séduisant on
le connaissait pas il a quand même été
éludée votre démocratiquement donc je
pense pas que ce soit un défaut de
communication de personnalité il est
très intelligent comme tous les
présidents comme mais c'est un an sous
estime parfois la temporalité des
événements et de la communication c'est
la limite du en même temps peut-être oui
là on est un fait dans l'extrême vers
même temps le 11 novembre vous allez
chez renault oui bien sûr ça le discours
qu'il avait accès aux sujets
intéressants il est courageux
well pas au milieu d'autres
manifestations qui n'ont rien à voir
avec ça c'est bientôt autant même temps
c'est faire ma vie il fait profiter de
ses deux de la guerre du centenaire de
14,8 pour défendre son bilan ça n'a rien
à voir
d'ailleurs il perd sur tous les tableaux
puisque l'on retient pas ce qu'ils
disent sur l'eau 14-18 et il aima
convaincant sur son île et guillaume
héras que ces banques impression d'un
public soit interpellé comme n'importe
quel quidam comme vous moi dans la rue
écoutez il crée les conditions pour
pouvoir l'être en fin de giro personne
de weeds on y pense que c'est de croire
que les services il ne voulait pas être
interpellé n'y aurait pas des cordons de
sécurité qui empêcherait qui
entraînerait sa donc en fait c'est une
stratégie et pour aussi essayer de
montrer qu'il est proche de ses
électeurs le problème c'est qu'en fait
il est on l'a dit mais il faut vraiment
insisté
ibilité de son discours c'est de sa
faute est par ailleurs la faiblesse des
manuels macron c'est qu'il a été élu par
défaut
je vous rappellerai quand même que c'est
la seule fois hormis 1969 où on a un
président de la république qui est élu
au second tour avec une baisse de la
participation par rapport au premier
tour et qu'on a eu un record
d'abstention au premier tour des
élections législatives en fait macro
incarne je dirais la grande coalition
mais sans parachute
c'est là que s'il ne réussit pas qu'est
ce qui se passe politiquement parlant
avec le spectre politique tel qu'il
s'est recomposée si lui ne réussit pas
qu'est ce qui va rester comme offre
politique crédible pour et bien les
français et je crois que aussi bien je
dirais là le côté hargneuse je dirais de
certaines questions de certaines
interpellations que tu dirais l'embarras
dans laquelle il est pour pour répondre
et bien manifeste
incontestablement le fait que là on est
au pied du mur est-ce que c'est à dire
c'est la france qui votent pas que
qu'eux mêmes à croix rencontré cette
semaine celles qui n'y croient plus à la
politique
oui c'était un peu d'ailleurs c'était ce
qui est un peu malsain dans cette
campagne là parce que c'est la france de
14-18 celle de l'est et du nord elle
recoupe la france qui y croient plus
trop en la politique
la france qui votent marine le pen et la
france qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup moins
que l'autre partie de la france voté
emmanuel macron au deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
donc c'était dans ces régions-là qui lui
sont moins acquise qu'il a voulu aller
pour aussi défendre son bilan as mais à
mon sens le le pari de communication est
tout sauf réussi il ya tant de choses à
dire c'est à dire le fait qu'ils aient
eu un sacrifice nationale et le fait de
dire voilà nous sommes confrontés un
certain nombre de crises économiques
identitaires et c est donc il est
nécessaire que nous fassions tous
ensemble un certain nombre de sacrifices
comme n'osant threat ont fait 1 sec le
sacrifice de leur vie pour pouvoir
redresser le corps social
eh bien ils avaient l'occasion de le
dire et il n'en profite même pas vous a
posé la question
à vous chers internautes du figaro c'est
même la question du jour pour savoir si
emmanuel macron avait eu raison ou non
de se lancer cette semaine sur le
terrain vous dites plutôt non à 58 %
mais c'est quand même relativement
partagés et puis bien sûr vous réagissez
sur lefigaro.fr sur twitter merci chers
internautes qui est en train de nous
suivre
christophe qui nous dit hypocrisie de
macron personne de croix qu'il a
apprécié les remontrances du peuple
christophe nous dit nous sommes nous de
christophe nous dit encore nous sommes
passés à côté de l'hommage peut être que
dimanche avec les autres chefs d'état il
y aura plus de recueillement ou puisque
dimanche il y aura une rencontre
effectivement avec tous les grands
responsables du monde dont donald trump
et one shot dit méchamment itinérance
mémorielle ou égarements présidentielle
pour l'interrogation a déroulé ce
dimanche on a eu jeudi vendredi samedi
sont nationales notamment par exemple
sur l'absence de défilé militaire
oui voilà qu'est ce qui a été voulu pour
éviter de fâcher ans gasquet madame
merkel c'est quand même une victoire
militaire je veux dire l'histoire et dès
là c'est pas autre chose et donc c'est
aux troupes françaises de défiler sur
les champs-élysées ça n'a rien de nids
de réactionnaire ni de passer peut-être
y aura-t-il alors une nouvelle polémique
jusqu'à dimanche
on parle d'un autre sujet mais on reste
sur le la politique et les convictions
des manuels macron edouard philippe le
disait ce matin dans un message publié
sur facebook le nombre d actes
antisémites a augmenté de +2 69% au
cours des neuf premiers mois de l'année
d'où cette question qui revient est ce
que nous sommes en train de revivre une
période sombre de l'histoire de l'europe
celle des années 30 c'est en tout cas la
conviction des manuels macron il leur
disait encore mardi dernier dans un
entretien à nos confrères d'europe 1 et
moi je suis frappé de voir deux choses
qui ressemble terriblement aux années 30
le fait que notre europe a été bousculé
par une crise économique et financière
profonde qui a plongé des pays dans
des crises extrêmement dur sur le plan
social vous connaissez bien la grèce da
grèce le portugal et nous voyons à
nouveau une montée des nationalismes qui
jouent sur ces peurs qui ont bernard
allez allez allez juste cette analogie
alors écoutez j'aurais envie de vous
dire ce qu'a dit zemmour ce que la
question que zemmour a posé en disant
mais alors dans ce cas là quel rôle joue
t'il si nous sommes dans les années 30
et daladier c'est camille chautemps quel
rôle joue notre ami macron s'était pas
tout à fait ma question j'essaie
attention c'était clairement sincèrement
est-ce qu'il est juste non je ne je ne
pense pas je pense que les l'histoire ne
repasse pas les plats que l'on à des
circonstances qui sont parfaitement
comment dire différentes et que le fait
de vouloir assimiler
je dirais des périodes ainsi ne
a pour but est évidemment de créer une
situation mais ni kent où il y aurait
les gentils et les méchants
sous-entendu ceux qui sont dans le fond
aujourd'hui susceptibles de contester la
construction européenne telle qu'elle se
fait de discuter je dirais des flux
migratoires de mettre en avant une
insécurité culturelle et morale dans le
corps social ne serait finalement que
des gens qui adorent et adopté
l'idéologie nazie
sincèrement ce n'est pas sérieux ce
n'est pas sérieux
quant à la question de l'antisémitisme
plus précisément je crois que là aussi
on fait semblant de croire que les
causes je dirais qu ayant mené à ces
actes antisémites seraient les mêmes
aujourd'hui que dans les années 30
personne n'ose hier alors que enfin s'il
ya quand même un savon aux personnes qui
le disent que incontestablement
l'origine actuel de l'antisémitisme et
des actes antisémites c'est
essentiellement c'était essentiellement
ressort islamistes et donc par
conséquent je crois que vouloir faire
cette comparaison me paraît malsain
tu l'as de finale comparaison n'est
jamais raison ça pour le coup et je
trouve ça toujours être chromatique
voire absurde de comparer des périodes
historiques
ça n'a jamais tout à fait nages m ces
deux n 1 kronis mais exactement essais
et c'est tout à fait faux et là les
points de ressemblance peuvent tourner
virer vite à l'indécence je trouve quand
on peut quand on compare mais dans le
mouvement de mélenchon mouvement de
marine le pen
ad
idéologie totalitaire comme le
stalinisme nazisme c'est presque
indécent pour ceux qui ont véritablement
souffert de ces totalitarisme aulas mais
ça explique quoi en fait la généalogie
de ça s'est vraiment joué sur
l'idéologie de la peur on a quand même
peur d'à peu près tout dans notre
société actuelle alors que ça ne
justifie pas forcément et jouer
instrumentaliser la peur des gens et
jouer sur les émotions c'est vraiment de
la politique émotionnelle mais pas du
tout rationnel et je trouve ça et je
trouve que cette ces fausses
ressemblance tourne vraiment à
l'indécence de régulièrement
ouais plusieurs choses m'ont déjà sur le
l'antisémitisme
alors moi j'ai été regardé les chiffres
de l'antisémitisme sur le long terme
en réalité c'est une courbe sinusoïdale
c'est à dire que ça baisse
où ça descend de 50% à peu près tous les
ans donc séparé en baisse depuis deux
ans absolument donc au jour cette année
ça augmente de 60 9%
c'est pas une tendance sur plusieurs
années donc on peut pas en tirer une
conclusion sur plusieurs années première
chose mon deuxième chose puis d'accord
avec tout ce qui a été dit cette
comparaison avec les années 30
elle a surtout un intérêt politique qui
est de faire peur et d'apparaître
électoralement comme un rempart à la
barbarie qui ferait représenter par les
nationalistes nouveau navy ça veut pas
dire que faut pas s'inquiéter de la
montée des nationalismes
mais c'est qu'il est beaucoup trop pv de
juste expliquer qu'on est dans un climat
pré années 30 et donc qu'il faut voter
c'est là que la fameuse couverture de
libération avant le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle faites ce que vous voulez
mais votez macron voilà en réalité le
message tout tendues c'est celui là très
intéressant que le débat politique
puisse aller un peu plus loin sur les
idées par exemple je vous donne des
points de vue de d'internautes
christophe qui nous dit comparaison
n'est pas raison l'antisémitisme le 2018
n'est pas celui des années 30
un autre internaute de 10 ce chiffre ne
vient-il pas du fait que ces actes sont
plus répertoriés et que les actes
d'agression dans leur ensemble donc pas
seulement les actes antisémites augmente
et w2
une stratégie pour les élections
européennes et tania nous dit pourquoi
regarder seulement les chiffres sur deux
ans quelle évolution sur 10 ou 20 ans on
a comme on a essayé de vous répondre à
l'instant tania et one shoot nous dit le
problème c'est de prendre un critère est
d'en faire une généralité
on n'est pas vraiment dans les années 30
on trouve pas grand monde pour l'instant
pour défendre le point de vue du
président est-ce que vous c'est ça va
être votre cas daniel bilalian je suis
d'accord il s'y était dit c'est-à-dire
comparer la situation actuelle aux
années 30 et dire d'une certaine façon
il ya une nationalisme le populisme
serait une montée de l'antisémitisme
c'est sous-entendu ça me paraît un tout
petit peu bizarre et aujourd'hui en
france par exemple les 11 millions de
français qui ont voté marine le pen ne
sont pas des antisémites au sarment aux
camarades de son père mais en tout cas
ce sont des gens qui se plaignent de
leur vie de leur vie et de la
mondialisation etc
donc je trouve trouve très dangereux de
laisser à penser que c'est que c'est ça
mais c'est sa grande son grand combat
laurent wauquiez l'a dit l'autre jour le
président république et cynique il dit
c'est moi ou le nationalisme
ils essayent de supprimer ce qui était
la droite le rpr udf et c'est donc c'est
très intelligent de sa part et en même
temps très cynique c'était c'est moi ou
le nationalisme c'est moi ou
l'antisémitisme sous-entendus je trouve
ça un petit peu fort de café
et en plus je pense que honnêtement
français moyen il fait pas de référence
à sa y compris contre ce jour-là il
comprend pas comprend pas ce qu'on lui
dit il comprend pas qu'on ait brisé ne
fait que favoriser parce que c'est quand
un monde où un homme met ta femme est
abominable l'affreuse banane ya rien de
mieux pour la valoriser il va la trouver
parce que je reviens c'est exactement ce
que je reproche mois alors ça c'est au
premier ce matin lorsqu'il fait cette
intervention sur facebook c'est toujours
le politiquement correct on ne dit pas
d'où viendrait l'antisémitisme
d'aujourd'hui mais on sait que
l'antisémitisme vient principalement de
l'islam radical
mais ça on ne le dit pas on ne dit rien
on dit rien au cas où
au cas où donc là encore le français
moyen lui dit voilà il n'ose pas dire
que l'islam radical
c'est le
fournisseur essentiel et principal de
l'antisémitisme voilà seulement la
déclaration de moi je ne sais pas
comment un premier ministre dire voilà
il ya il se passe quelque chose et ne
pas dire d'où ça vient
ces scènes de violences et bien que pour
parler de la délinquance ond parler des
jeunes
alors elle sait très bien qui a proposé
les conditions qui ont conduit ce plutôt
certains a nécessairement volontairement
mais qui les conduisent plutôt à je
verrai participer à ça à ces actes
délictueux et donc par conséquent
évidemment il y à un risque pour le coup
évidemment de ce que cette dénonciation
fort légitime puisse se retourner contre
ceux qui évidemment cherche à exploiter
politiquement
et puis il ya aussi un autre élément
c'est que s'il y a je dirais des actes
contre je dirais certaines catégories de
la population ne faut pas oublier qu'il
y a des profanations d'églises des
profanations de cimetières chrétiens qui
sont là aussi pour le coup plutôt en
augmentation alors ça n'est sans doute
pas que le fait je dirais de du
multiculturalisme et de la présence du
raid à l'islam conquérant en france il
ya aussi évidemment toutes les sectes
sataniques etc
mais il est incontestable que ne pas
nommer je dirais les causes ou du moins
certaines causes susceptibles d'être à
l'origine d'un phénomène
eh bien ça ne me paraît pas très
respectueux ni de ceux à qui on
s'adresse ni efficace pour pouvoir gérer
la question on vous pose la question sur
twitter un est ce que cette comparaison
est pertinente quand on parle de la
montée de l'antisémitisme et du
populisme vous considérez
majoritairement que non à 76 % ont plus
demandés ginger si le président la
république lui même n'est pas en train
de revenir un petit peu sur 7 sur cet
argument un peu un peu simple ou un peu
un peu binaire
dans la même interview à europe 1 il
expliquait que l'europe était ultra
libérale que elle ne permettait plus aux
classes moyennes de vivre correctement
arguments qu'on entendait classiquement
plutôt chez ce que emmanuel macron
appelé jusque là les populistes oui
il essaye de jouer sur tous les tableaux
mais en réalité cet argument là on
l'entend d'à peu près tous les partis
avant les élections européennes
on a rare on entend rarement des partis
se satisfaire de la bonne marche et du
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes avant les élections c'est la
figure imposée d'expliquer que l'idée
européenne est une superbe idée mais que
oui il ya des ça fonctionne pas très
bien et qu'on va le faire beaucoup mieux
fonctionner et où des abus et on va
faire beaucoup faire ça beaucoup mieux
fonctionner dans les années à venir
bon est-ce qu'il est crédible sur cette
thématique là pas forcément parce que
tous ces actes depuis qu'il a été élu
vont dans le sens de ce que font les
européistes que fait la commission
européenne à l'échelle de l'union à part
d'ombré
et puis la dénonciation du nationalisme
encore faut-il s'entendre sur ce qui est
dénoncé
parce que quand on fait l'histoire du
mot je vous renvoie notamment aux
travaux de jean pierre des scot sur
cette question le nationalisme ça peut
être un nationalisme impérialistes c'est
effectivement le sens qu'il a lorsque
valmy vive la nation la révolution
française qui veut porter les idéaux
au delà des frontières mais ça peut être
aussi le nationalisme de réaction c'est
à dire le nationaliste de protection
lorsque et bien il ya l'agression
allemande en 1870 lorsque il y a dû dire
et 1 1 comment dire une forme de de
désorganisation du corps social par 9e
comment dire par par les situations la
situation fait je dirais aux catégories
les plus populaires donc le nationalisme
tel qu'il peut apparaître à la fin des
années à la fin du 19e siècle
il peut avoir deux facettes la facette
du nationalisme révolutionnaire ou la
facette du nationalisme de réaction est
plutôt protectionnistes donc c'est
cesser encore faut-il de poids à savoir
de quoi l'on parle
et mettre dans le même sac je dirais les
différentes sensibilités que ce même
terme qui est polysémique peut recouvrir
ça me paraît
idéologiquement effectivement discutable
oui j'allais aller exactement dans le
même sens le problème ces problèmes des
mots c'est à dire que on édulcore et on
adoucit tout le langage pour ne pas
signifier les vraies causes et les vrais
dangers
donc les mots on a peur que le mot
chiens mordent à la limite c'est
vraiment un problème du nominalisme et
de l'autre côté on sort des grands mots
des gros mots capitalisme libéralisme
comme si c'était des boucs émissaires et
des explications de tous c'est vraiment
un problème de langage un moment il faut
parler avec des mots vrais et je pense
pour revenir sur la colère des gens dans
les provinces c'est ça aussi donc ils
ont marre un peu de ces de ces poncifs
ils ont envie de se confronter à la
réalité et notamment les réalités des
mots il est politiquement correct mais
aussi des mots très durs par exemple
lorsqu'il parle des populistes de la
lèpre populiste et moi c'est ce mot
populiste à partir de vent ou les
parties deviennent majoritaires dans
leur pays devienne populaire à partir
vous avez la majorité vous n'êtes plus
populiste au sens négatif du type vous
êtes populaire qu'est ce que cette façon
de parler
c'est le résultat du vote démocratique
alors on peut le regretter mais c'est
ainsi
cette émission est importante d'abord
parce qu'on a bondi plein de choses
passionnantes et en plus parce que nous
allons essayer de réparer une injustice
il paraît que on a été trop dur avec
françois hollande et qu'il faut
réhabiliter l'ancien président de la
république
c'est en tout cas le point de vue de la
fondation jean jaurès qui est un think
tank de sensibilité sociale démocrate
qui en gros 10 mai il a fait plein de
choses françois hollande pour le climat
pour la baisse des déficits
il a créé des postes de fonctionnaires
dans l'éducation ils abaisser les
charges et et simplement on a été trop
injuste avec lui écouter ce que dit
gilles finchelstein c'est le directeur
général de cette fondation prise
isolément
la plupart des mesures était approuvée
par les français mais prise globalement
elle été massivement rejetée à aucun
moment ni françois hollande ni les
autres responsables n'ont véritablement
tenté de donner la cohérence de la
politique qui a été suivie cette
intéressante cette cet argument en gros
c'est parce que il n'a pas réussi à
vendre sa politique mais alors qu'elle
était en surface il ya des gens qui
parlent comprends pas
j'ai compris ce qu'il voulait dire
c'était bien mais c'était pas bien c'est
bien dit il dit c'était bien mais ça n'a
pas été bien communiquer et bien mises
en scène et mise en musique comme moi si
par exemple on ne baisse les impôts
c'est bien que vous communiquez bien ou
pas bien si vous me baisser les impôts
50% je suis d'accord dire des choses
dans sa vie il faut des choses sont
simples je vivais à dire général de
gaulle quand il a décidé de les rendre
jerry de libérer l'algérie l'a dit on va
faire un vote pour ou contre l'algérie
française c'est sympa il se pourrait que
néanmoins mais en plus non je reviens
parce que ça me fascine chaque fois j'ai
l'impression
je comprends où il y en a un souci là
non je pense que moi je pense
sincèrement pour pour le pour l'avoir
connu au long de ma carrière avant quand
il était premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste
cet homme là était là par hasard
normalement c'est pas lui c'est strauss
kahn
il se trouve qu'en politique retrouver
un type un prix un président potentiel
en slip dans le couloir c'est pas tous
les jours que ça arrive ça c'est sûr et
certain
donc il est là par hasard et moi je n'ai
fréquenté cet homme là cette charge
était trop lourde pour lui et c'est pour
ça qu'il a eue ce parcours un peu
chaotique
parce que même s'il a fait des choses
bien je veux dire souvenez vous quand
même il ya le jour de la vente il fait
un discours à versailles sur la
déchéance nationale 99 9 % des français
sont d'accord et il ne le fait pas
presque
et il ne fait pas et il ne fait pas
deuxièmement son parcours il est
chaotique aussi par des choses
anecdotiques par exemple il va au chevet
du dino météo alors qu'on sait pas
exactement si quoi etc
les français disent la vidéo il va au
chevet d'un gars qui vendait de la
drogue
voilà c'est simple le jugement il est
fait alors je parle même pas du scooter
parce que là s'imagine dans la région
vous imaginez vous vous dites le
président de la république le toute la
journée alors qu'il est en train de
parler avec obama et ses 10 ans hier ce
soir faut pas que je me trompe d'heure
faut que j'arrête un trailer d'un
atelier avec cette les rails c'est non
mais vous dis c'est pas si c'est pas
sérieux c'est pas sérieux et c'est des
petites choses comme ça c'est oui mais
c'est comme ça ainsi c'est là dessus que
nous jugeons non c'est là dessus que
nous jugeons c'est vrai mais quand même
c'est que c'est injuste fngra parce que
parce que c'est pas faux qu'il a baissé
les déficits françois hollande
il a même mené une vraie politique
sociale démocrate il
baisser les charges sur les entreprises
oui oui si on regarde compta de façon
totalement comptable son bilan n'est pas
forcément déshonorant sauf que la
politique c'est pas des lignes de compte
la politique c'est donner de l'espoir
aux gens et c'est sur ça qu'il a
complètement flanché et qui l'a trahi
parce que françois hollande qu'on le
veuille ou non il est lu par une partie
des gens sur sa phrase mon ennemi n'a
pas de visage et c'est la finance par
une partie du peuple de gauche
en tout cas et le jour où il est élu wii
prend sa place de président de la
république il fait pas du tout ça est le
tournant de fin 2013 que il annonce le
pack de responsabilité le cic eux les 40
milliards donnés aux entreprises bah là
il a eu des fois il déçoit beaucoup
parce que avril ayant on leur a dit phil
là il y aura plus de redistribution et
ils n'ont pas vu plus de rodrigues
distribution donc peut en effet
peut-être que le quand on arrête le
compteur à mai 2010 est il ya moins de
déficits le chômage n'a pas tellement
augmenté il a même commencé à
redescendre vers la fin sauf que
politiquement le compte n'y est
absolument pas et d'ailleurs cette
réhabilitation mais en même en creux de
la fondation jean jaurès
elle veut tout dire la fondation jean
jaurès sa a été créée par pierre mauroy
c'est des sociaux-démocrates c'est pas
des mélenchonistes s'y met 12 sur 20 à
françois hollande qui fait partie de
leur famille politique c'est qu'il ya eu
un hiatus qui est parce qu il le note
aussi voir comment j'ai du mal à trouver
sur ce plateau des gens qui défendent
françois hollande donc je me tourne vers
les internautes et plus tôt pas tant que
ça s'arrange anti mac nous dit on est
jamais trop dur avec françois hollande
royal plein de smiley derrière quand
même
l'acropole c'est un pseudonyme nous dit
ci dessus on écoute finkelstein l'échec
du hollande c'est la faute à pas de
chance
quant à nicolas noguier assez drôlement
la seule chose positive que je retiens
des cinq ans de hollande sait qu'il aura
réussi à tuer le ps guillaume bernard
votre point de vue est ce qu'on n'a pas
été trop sévère quand même avec l'ancien
président la légitimité politique savait
on la trouve de deux manières
il ya la légitimité d'origine et puis à
la légitimité d'exercice légitimité
d'origine il a été désigné selon le
processus prévu aujourd'hui c'est une
élection très bien donc il avait la
légitimité politique pour exercer le
pouvoir
après ce qui fait véritablement est
encore plus profondément la légitimité
d'un homme politique ou d'un courant
politique c'est le fait qu'ils réalisent
effectivement le bien commun ou
l'intérêt général moi je préfère bien
commun mais bon le bien commun c'est de
la manière dont ils l'exercent
et ça vient d'être dit le problème de
beaucoup de nos hommes politiques c'est
le problème de françois hollande mais de
bien d'autres c'est qu'en fait ils
n'arrivent pas à comprendre que c'est
pas sur une série de mesures que ils
vont être jugés mais sur l'objectif dans
le fond les discours politiques
n'arrivent plus à dégager une finalité
un objectif à atteindre et puis ensuite
par pragmatisme ou partent choix
politiques décidées avec les français eh
bien on décide de mettre en oeuvre telle
ou telle mesure
ce qui je dirais détruit la réputation
de françois hollande mais de bien
d'autres aussi
c'est qu'en fait on ne savait pas là où
ils allaient gouverner alors là je vais
pardon je vais faire un peu d'étymologie
c'est guy bernard et c'est tenir le
gouvernail
on ne sait pas où aller où vous ou
françois hollande voulait aller alors je
trouve ça comment dire dommage parce que
là pour le coup c'était plus de là je
suis pas sûr de la garder dans mes
archives
alors que par ailleurs je trouve qu'il
ya des travaux de la fondation jean
jaurès qui sont vraiment intéressants
jambes four qui a fait quelque chose sur
la corse soit le vote encore ce votre
nation encore ce qui a été fait avec la
fondation jean jaurès qui sont qui est
une étude vraiment très intéressante
celle là je suis pas sûr qu'elle reste
dans les annales
julia de funès ou êtes mon dernier
espoir pour avoir un problème de
conservation
il était jaloux large et non non non bah
il est de bon ton de réhabiliter tout le
monde on réhabilite robespierre on
réhabilite pétain on réhabilite au nom
de toute façon c'est une mode la
réhabilitation mais non au delà de ça et
d'ailleurs dans l'étude l'élu rapidement
et ils disent en gros problème de qom et
crise d'autorité mais je pense que au
delà de toutes les mesures qu'on peut
discuter mais dont on peut discuter
c'est aussi un énorme problème
d'autorité
aujourd'hui on a eu affaire avec
hollande à un leader qui n'avait aucun
charisme et aucune autorité
or aujourd'hui dans cette ère
égalitariste que nous vivons c'est
exactement la même chose en entreprise
il ya beaucoup de managers qui n'ont
aucune compétence managériale et qui son
manager par promotion hélas après ce
qu'était un président par promotion
puisque par compétence d'autorité pas d'
autoritarisme et d'autorité et c'est ce
qui a créé ce manque de séduction parce
qu'en fait il rien de plus séduisant que
quelqu'un qui est une conviction des
profondeurs qui désirent son désir sa
volonté c'est la volonté de puissance je
vais pas philosopher on a déjà eu
l'étymologie on va pas physiquement mais
c'est ça en fait la volonté de puissance
avoir envie de sa propre envie
signe que c'est trop compliqué c'est un
peu johnny hallyday quand on a envie de
son envie on est très séduisant et lui
on avait l'impression qu'ils avaient pas
une conviction ou une finalité c'est ce
que vous disiez très marqué à tel point
que
du coup le président peut-être quelqu'un
de normal est quelqu'un de normal peut
être président ça a été une énorme
erreur
le charisme de l'autorité n'est pas la
chose du monde la mieux partagée
et il ya des mais le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui dès qu'on dit qu'il faut
des différences on a l'impression que
les différences on désigne des
injustices et non il ya des gens qui ont
plus ou moins de charisme ou non et la
deuxième le 2 le deuxième travers je
pense c'est qu'il a joué la carte du
normal et du président normal par
réaction à l'hyperprésident qui était
nicolas sarkozy et se positionner
toujours en réaction par rapport à
quelqu'un dire en gros ce qui a été fait
c'était mal et moi je vais faire le
contraire donc c'est bien c'est jamais
très séduisant non plus c'est une
inversion morale assez facile être dans
la réaction c'est pas être dans l'action
et ça manque forcément un peu de panache
et c'est le piège dans lequel macron est
en train de tomber parce que s'il
n'existe lui que par réaction au
populisme le populisme balle va
évidemment leurs adversaires
pour ce qui concerne à l'enjeu pas dire
je le connais très bien je connais
suffisamment de cet homme s'ennuyer au
cou cet homme s'ennuyer et on avait
vraiment le sentiment quand on ne
connaissait un peu franchement c'était
un mauvais moment à passer pour lui là
il pas pu faire autrement si ça lui est
arrivé par hasard parce que en plus les
français ont renvoyé sarkozy elle est
encore lié au sida a été découvert
défaut et cet homme sans mouiller au
pouvoir c'était c'était des pour lui
c'était interminable et c'était pas sa
vie autant être président du conseil
général de corrèze est allé à la foire
au jambon de tulsa c'est son truc
les sacs président a accueilli française
c'était au delà de ce qu'il pouvait la
durée je suis persuadée de ce que je dis
on vous pose la question sur twitter
faut-il réhabiliter françois hollande
ben c'est pas gagné parce que 80 % à
nous répondent non en évidence pas un
sondage c'est un point de vue que vous
exprimer en direct au fur et à mesure de
l'émission
christian nous dit holland a été une
cata pour tous christophe pose cette
question mais génial la réponse qui
finance la fondation jean jaurès sais
pas si quelqu'un nom de miss aisne
mais c'est une fondation d'un terrain
public s'est pas exactement quel une
expression qui donc a les dons sont
défiscalisées et en même temps la
dernière chose c'est qu'il n'a pas osé
se représenter ça confirme ce que vous
pouvez continuer c'est une réponse
bref il était là tirer des conséquences
de ces 52 plaisir peut-être at-il été
effectivement le premier juge de son
bilan par cette décision
il nous reste quelques minutes pour
parler d'un dernier sujet un peu plus
léger sans doute
celui de l'argent et du football il ya
un certain nombre de révélations qui
sortent ces jours ci dans différents
médias sur l'argent du foot on savait
qu'on avait beaucoup
on apprend ainsi que neymar la star
brésilienne du psg gagne 37 millions
d'euros par an mais comme c'est pas
beaucoup faut bien reconnaître il a
droit en plus à 375000 euros par mois
alors ça s'appelle une prime des tic
alors on pensait que l'éthique ça
consistait à bien jouer ou à respecter
ses adversaires pas du tout l'éthique ça
consiste à aller faire risette aux
supporters à la fin du match
daniel bilalian vous et vous être
surpris par tous et toutes ces réveils
avaient été le patron des sports de
france télévisions connais un peu ce
domaine il faut être prêt tout à fait
juste les 370 mille euros c'est énorme
mais ce n'est pas uniquement pour aller
saluer le public même si ça peut sembler
extraordinaire que ça se passe comme ça
c'est peu c'est pour se tenir
correctement pour répondre à un certain
nombre d'interviews pour ne pas empêcher
les médias d'où paris ça c'est pas
uniquement pour lire merci parce que les
enfants 2300 ça tombe bien se tenir
ça fait partie ça fait partie mais c'est
pas une blague on est absolument fausse
et c'est là
c'est l'origine les joueurs qu'on engage
c'est ça le vrai scandale alors
effectivement le paris sg qui qui a tenu
des des fichiers ethniques sur les
origines des jeunes footballeurs recruté
en forme alors que la première chose
c'est que le type qui a fait ça par
écrit c'est un imbécile parce qu'il peut
très bien décider sans encensant
l'écrire lui qu'il a donnée le document
il a fait le document pour se faire
renvoyer
c est fini mais c'est sans doute vrai
c'est sans doute vrai et pas qu'au paris
saint germain
aujourd'hui si oui le sport n'est plus
du sport ce set ce sont des entreprises
il ya quelques années encore les clubs
étaient des entreprises sportives
locales municipales et des parler parler
des industries de la région aujourd'hui
ce sont des entreprises commerciales ou
politiques comme le qatar ou la chine
qui se sont engagés dans le monde du
football donc ce serait entrepris terre
du ps voilà profitèrent du plaisir et le
qatar c'est que il a un public à paris
il faut lui offrir une diversité des
origines de ses joueurs pour que non
plus les spectateurs ses clients sont
ses clients viennent au stade
regardez dans d'autres domaines toutes
les publicités aujourd'hui pour tous les
produits que vous connaissez il y à des
blancs des africains des gens d'origine
asiatique et c'est parce qu'on est dans
un monde de marchandises donc le
football comme d'autres sports mais
principalement le football n'est plus un
sport
ce sont des chefs d'entreprise que ceux
qui veulent faire fructifier leurs gains
et donc pour ça ils savent qu'ils ont
besoin d'avoir un public qu'une
clientèle très différenciée dont il faut
pas exagérer dans lentilles et il faut
pas exagérer dans l'africain faut pas
exagérer dans ce cycle dans cela ça
donne une équipe à paris où il n'y a pas
un seul joueur qui parle français
alors ça c'était sur le sujet 1 du 2d
des fichiers tic mais si on en revient à
l'argent du football
une autre information donnée c'est que
outre son salaire de 17 millions annuels
qu'il allait me bat p le célèbre
champion du monde français quitte lui
aussi joue au psg touche 10 millions
d'euros ou plus exactement le club paye
à sa place c'est 10 millions d'euros
d'impôts il s'en est expliqué d'ailleurs
un petit peu gêné quand même regarder je
n'aime pas trop parler de ce sujet mais
vu que vous m'en parlez je vais en
parler
voilà je tiens à préciser déjà que je
paye tous mes impôts en france
surtout mes revenus on a annoncé
différentes choses et que voilà pour moi
le plus important c'était de savoir dans
quel club je pouvais donner le meilleur
de moi même et poursuivre ma progression
et j'ai choisi le paris saint germain
tout naturellement après voilà il faut
pas oublier qu'il ya des négociations et
que tout ce que j'ai fait même s'il ya
plein de choses qui sont fausses
je les fait dans les règles voilà une
map et qui était au micro de nos
confrères de france info
julia de funès finalement c'est c'est
l'offre et la demande de dire que tous
savaient pas choquant en soi si à ce qui
est paradoxal en tout cas ce qui est oui
pourquoi ça à chaque pas socialo moss
est dégoûté d'ailleurs ce qui est
paradoxal c'est que on appelle sa prime
des tic est justement j'étais toujours
facile je me suis toujours questionné
sur pourquoi les idoles aujourd'hui sont
les idoles sportifs se sont absolument
plus les hommes politiques on l'a
suffisamment montré ce soir ce ne sont
plus les philosophes les intellectuels
se sont mbacké et j'allais dire zidane
mais je pense que c'est totalement
démodé
c'est que neymar bardon neymar griezmann
etc et philosophiquement on peut
expliquer cet engouement pour le sport
parce que le sport c'est le seul domaine
où l'égalité des droits et des
inégalités réelles vont être
réconciliées le plus fort c'est le
meilleur il ya des inégalités énormes
mais c'est normal parce qu'il doit cette
cette position-là à son mérite à ses
efforts à cette discipline est plus à
des classes sociales et adhésifs et des
privilèges parfois injustifiées
donc le sport c'est une résolution d'une
contradiction démocratique assez forte
et c'est pour ça aussi cet engouement
aujourd'hui pour le sport qui sort du
sport vous avez raison c'est devenu une
entreprise et dans les entreprises ont
fait appel aux sportifs et les
entreprises et les managers géré leur
équipe comme des sportifs c'est marrant
de coach comme des coachs comme des
sportifs il ya des grands footballeurs
qui viennent expliquer comment il faut
souder le collectif au sein des équipes
ce qui est complètement aberrante jeu
n'a rien à voir c'est comme les
comparaisons historiques
vous imaginez un manager dire à chaque
heure kabir de bureau et vas-y à fond
comme deschamps c'est pas possible
bref
du coup ça cet engouement pour le sport
on le comprend démocratiquement et
c'était vraiment le lieu de la morale
finalement démocratique les inégalités
sont justes dans le sport et c'est c'est
ce qui est choquant c'est que justement
il ya cette prime des tic qui sont tout
sauf éthique qui viennent dans ce monde
éthique c'est à la limite un financier
qui qui fraudent c'est presque moins
gênant je dis pas que c'est moins grave
mais c'est moins gênant parce que la
finance est mâtiné pas matinée de morale
et même matinée de 10 moralité ou de
d'amoralité peu importe
moi jai ho mais on est moins surpris
mais là c'est vraiment un des domaines
de la morale par excellence donc c'est
d'autant plus choquant ou le pose la
question 1 sur twitter et de vous
dégoûter par le business dans le milieu
du football
vous êtes près des deux tiers à nous
répondre oui est-ce aussi votre cas et
angie rares ou est ce que tout ça bah
finalement c'est rien que du business
bah écoutez je n'ai pas appris que le
foot business déborder d'argent avec
avec cette enquête
mais oui évidemment de quoi être écoeuré
et il est quelque chose de surréaliste à
entendre qu'il y en ait maps et se
gausse de 19 ans par les deux mécanismes
d'optimisation fiscale et oui tout ce
que j'ai fait est légal
j'ai juste produire absolument non mais
y'a rien à lui reprocher là dessus mais
j'ai juste profiter de ce que la loi
permet au plus haut plus de ce qu'on
peut faire
la vérité c'est que dans le monde du
foot et tous les suiveurs du foot le
dise un joueur qui ne fait pas ça qui ne
fait pas d'optimisation fiscale qui
n'essaye pas de gagner le plus possible
et plus que les autres il va pas être
respectée sur le terrain ac c'est comme
ça que ça marche
le foot business pour être le patron il
faut être le type qui demande le plus
d'argent etc obtient le plus d'argent
comme si en fait ce sport qui dégage de
superbes valeurs qui sont plutôt des
valeurs de solidarité de partage de
passe parce que c'est un sport collectif
on peut pas gagner tout seul et de
dépassement le soir avait un peu perdu
la tête
on a perdu la tête mais on est tous
responsables parce qu'on regarde tous
finalement ces milliardaires courir
après un ballon et en y prenant du
plaisir en plus sur twitter vous
réagissez un monsieur babineau qui nous
dit
il a tout à fait raison que le fichage
raciale est interdit par la loi et que
rien ne peut le justifier ce que nous
dit aussi au lin qui le dit en france ce
type de statistiques sont interdites
mais au canada par exemple elles sont
acceptées pour mieux aider les minorités
d'ailleurs guillaume bernard le foot ça
vous parle
ils ont que ça ne fait pas tout à fait
partie de mes spécialités que filière je
dois le reconnaître mais moi tous les
éléments qui ont été dits
mater roche vraiment si vous voulez vous
avez évoqué le fait que c'était légal
d'obtenir de tels salaires ou de telles
primes
bon moi qui suis plutôt en défenseurs du
droit naturel contre le droit positif je
ne ferai pas un scoop en disant ça je
pense que tout ce qui est légal n'est
pas forcément juste je pense que
honnêtement des salaires des
rémunérations de ce type sont
parfaitement indécente et très
sincèrement la question du fichage
ethnique ou la question de ces de ces
primes dites éthiques
eh bien elles ont un point commun ces
deux questions là c'est le fait que on a
totalement déshumanisé le sport qui est
supposé être l'incarnation
je dirais de l'effort justement humain
de la solidarité entre joueurs d'une
équipe pour gérer produire 1 comment
dire un un objectif qui est de faire
gagner un corps un corps collectif et
pas simplement des individus épars ou ce
combattant donc par conséquent là on est
quand même arrivé à un niveau de
rémunération est un niveau je dirais de
2 comment dire de d'instrumentalisation
de chosification des différents joueurs
pour pouvoir correspondre à un certain
communautarisme moins de certaines
affiches que l'on veut donner comme vous
le disiez ou aux clients ou que sont les
fans ou les supporters etc
on en est arrivé à akwa et bien on est
arrivé à subirait une situation bien
pire me semble-t-il que celle de l'
esclavage dans le monde antique les
laisser on exploite je dirais leur force
de travail mais en plus je dirais on va
y revenir quand il va elle valérie sont
pas ils sont ils sont là je suis pas si
sûr que vous qui est pas des clones
lectra est prévu qu'il ne prévoit ça le
sincèrement je crois que là on arrive à
un tel niveau que de déshumanisation de
ceux qui normalement devrait être une
activité
m parce que aussi si vous voulez le
problème du paris saint germain c'est
que c'est un pays qui s'appelle le qatar
qui se sert de ce club c'est un club
c'est une fonction politique ce club et
pauvres est le signal qu'ils ont fait
supprimer la croix pour rayonner un
gerland pour rayonner pour rayonner dans
le monde et c'est pour ça aussi qui vont
organiser la coupe du monde de football
par 40 degrés à l'ombre
je veux dire par là c'est certain et
donc ils auront ils mettront l'argent
qu'il faut avec tous les moyens qu'il
faut y resteront dans la légalité
par exemple vous sur un maillot
ordinaire de football vous allez payer
cent mille euros par an et le qatar va
mettre 3 millions qu'est ce que vous
dites merci daniel bilalian on va
laisser les mots de la rive un anti mac
qui nous dit je suis plus dégoûté je
suis plus dégoûtés pardon par le manque
croissant d'éthique en politique
désolé pour moi le foot est un problème
accessoires et bien on en a parlé quand
même cher anti mac parce que c'est
l'intérêt de cette émission c'est de
varier les sujets merci à tous de nous
avoir suivis et bien sûr point de vue
revient lundi prochain à la même heure
au même endroit très bon week-end merci
[Musique]
ce